en el vídeo anterior vimos una realidad
en el que la tasa de intercambio del
yuan y el dólar era de 10 a 1 y con esta
tasa de intercambio china enviaría más
productos hacia eeuu ya sea que lo midan
en dólares son yuanes enviaría más
productos a eeuu de lo que estados
unidos enviaría hacia china y debido a
esto vimos que existía una falta de
equilibrio entre las monedas el yuan se
volvía más caro y el dólar más barato
hasta que eventualmente los productos
chinos se volvían más caros tan caros
que ya no eran tan solicitados en eeuu y
por otra parte los productos de eeuu se
volvían lo suficientemente baratos como
para que aumentara la demanda de estos y
eventualmente la tasa de intercambio
llegaba a un equilibrio y bueno eso está
muy bien si todos quisieran que se
llegara a este equilibrio pero qué tal
si el gobierno chino no quisiera esto
qué tal si dijeran bueno nosotros
necesitamos desarrollarnos los eeuu ya
están desarrollados queremos tener una
base industrial y queremos tener un
mercado para vender nuestros productos
pues lo que queremos exportar más
hacia eeuu de lo que importamos de ellos
queremos que nuestra exportación crezca
y a ellos no les gusta esta dinámica no
quieren que el yuan se vuelva más caro
así que digamos que el gobierno chino
quiere mantener
el cambio
de divisas fijo
10 yuanes por dólar y esto lo quieren
así para mantener esta situación de acá
y que ésta no cambie nunca que china
envíe más productos hacia eeuu comparado
con los productos que se mandan de eeuu
hacia china y que los productos que se
envían de chinas sean cada vez mayores
para que china pueda construir su base
industrial y bueno otro punto de vista
un poco más siniestro es para provocar
que los eeuu tengan su base industrial a
la baja y así los chinos puedan
construir cosas mucho más barato y los
fabricantes de eeuu no puedan competir
pero esto lo veremos en más detalle en
los próximos vídeos ya que no está claro
al cien por ciento que esto sea sólo la
intención de uno de los lados también
hay elementos en eeuu que se
beneficiarían con esta situación pero lo
discutiremos más adelante así que el
gobierno de china quiere que esta
realidad permanezca congelada quieren
que ayudando permanezca devaluado y como
tendrían que intervenir ellos para que
esto suceda ya que habíamos visto que si
se envían más productos de china eeuu va
a haber más demanda de ayuda
y éste aumentará su valor y el dólar se
devaluará pero como podemos obtener
ambas cosas y enviar muchos productos de
china a eeuu y mantener el yuan a la
baja la forma de hacer esto es mediante
el gobierno chino en particular el banco
central chino que es parte de su
gobierno lo voy a dibujar por acá banco
central de china
qué es lo que van a hacer ellos lo que
ellos van a hacer es imprimir dinero
teniendo este escenario que expliquen
los vídeos anteriores tenemos este
desequilibrio ahí la demanda de mil
yuanes y una oferta o suministro de sólo
500 yuanes así que lo que pueden hacer
es igualar esto como pues imprimiendo
500 yuanes así que ellos imprimen 500
yuanes
y estos los transforman a dólares o los
cambian a dólares y ahora de pronto
tenemos 100 dólares que tratan de ser
convertidos a aproximadamente 1.000
yuanes si es que la tasa de intercambio
se mantuviera constante y habría una
demanda de millones y antes de que se
involucrará el banco central chino sólo
existían 500 yuanes como oferta o como
suministro pero ahora que el banco
central chino acaba de imprimir 500
yuanes más pues se cubre la demanda de
los mil yuanes y esos 500 yuanes
impresos se van a convertir en dólares
de manera que ahora ya tenemos un
balance entre la oferta y la demanda
tenemos 500 yuanes aquí 500 yuanes aquí
abajo y tenemos 100 dólares que quieren
ser convertidos a millones así que al
hacer esto así que al hacer esto la tasa
de intercambio de las monedas no van a
cambiar la oferta y la demanda de ambas
monedas permanecerá igual y esto
funciona de hecho lo han venido haciendo
durante cierto tiempo pero aquí hay un
detalle todo
porque hagan esto qué es lo que va a
suceder bueno van a seguir enviando más
productos hacia eeuu comparado con los
productos que envían los eeuu hacia
china estos tienen que seguir
imprimiendo más yuanes y transformar
esos yuanes en dólares para mantener el
balance entre ambas monedas y mantener
la moneda china barata por lo que van a
tener que estar acumulando dólares
imprimen yuanes y van a tener que estar
acumulando los dólares que obtuvieron ha
de transformar sus suanes así que el
banco central chino va a empezar a estar
acumulando muchos dólares imprimen todos
los yuanes que quieran los transforman a
dólares y van a tener que estar
acumulando todos esos dólares y mientras
más quieran mantener este balance en la
tasa de intercambio pues van a tener que
estar imprimiendo mayores y tener que
estar acumulando más dólares y de hecho
una vez comenzado esto no pueden
detenerse tienen que seguir haciéndolo
para mantener el balance en ambas
monedas en el siguiente vídeo veremos
qué es lo que tienen que hacer con todos
estos dólares ya que no los pueden
mantener como efectivo y veremos que lo
que hacen con estos dólares puede
afectar
economía de los eeuu y veremos cómo
podría deshacerse esto aunque es algo
bastante difícil de hacer una vez que se
ha comenzado